this video is sponsored by fabulous the
number one self-care app to help you
build better habits and achieve your
goals
on january 15th a submarine volcano
called hungatunga in the kingdom of
tonga exploded it had been erupting for
a few weeks but after a period of
relative calm the eruption became more
and more violent over a couple of days
and eventually produced a colossal
explosion the images of the eruption
from space are just shocking this thing
was enormous it basically deleted the
central part of the volcano that stuck
above the water and yet this explosion
was only half the story and it caused a
cascade of events around the world and
possibly was the very first time we've
ever observed a particular atmospheric
phenomenon on the local scale collisions
between the huge quantity of ash that
was injected into the atmosphere led to
a buildup and discharge of electric
charge and a frankly mind-blowing
display of volcanic lightning you can
clearly see where the plume of ash has
spread by the number of lightning
strikes in satellite imagery by one
count in three hours the eruption
produced 400 000 lightning strikes but
far more dangerous than the lightning
was the tsunami the eruption caused now
a tsunami is a very specific kind of
wave they are always caused by a mass
displacement of water typically by some
big event like an undersea earthquake or
a volcanic eruption
remember that it becomes important
because this eruption displaced a huge
amount of water maybe a few hundred
million tons a tsunami was triggered and
rapidly spread out through the pacific
now the first to be hit was the kingdom
of tonga whose capital nuku alifa is
just 40 miles away from the volcano you
can see the moment the tsunami hits
tonga as internet traffic with the
country just falls off a cliff and as of
the time of recording communication with
the country is still extremely sporadic
because the one undersea internet cable
to the country has been severed though
reports seem to indicate that the main
island has been badly hit though there
are no reports of mass casualties but
having said that we still haven't heard
from any of the outer islands the wave
then spread out across the pacific ocean
leading to tsunami warnings in other
island nations and eventually japan even
8 000 kilometers away the tsunami was
still a meter high though fortunately
doesn't seem to have caused any damage
here this much you've probably heard
elsewhere but this video isn't really
about the eruption or the tsunami i want
to talk briefly about the atmospheric
impact of the eruption which is global
two-fold and maybe unprecedented firstly
like all volcanic eruptions the events
of january 15th injected a large amount
of sulfur dioxide or so2 into the
atmosphere that's significant because
so2 reacts with water vapor in the
atmosphere to form tiny droplets of
sulfuric acid which can stick around for
a very long time especially if they
reach the stratosphere but why is that
important well those tiny droplets are
very reflective and in the aftermath of
large volcanic eruptions the earth's
atmosphere can become so reflective to
incoming solar radiation that it
noticeably cools the earth down when
mount pinatubo erupted in 1991 17
million tons of so2 was injected into
the atmosphere causing a global cooling
of around half a degree celsius in the
year or two after the eruption so a
reasonable question to ask this time
round is will this eruption result in
some global cooling will it buy us some
time in the fight against climate change
and the answer is unfortunately
probably not it's still early days but
initial estimates based on satellite
data indicate that the tongan eruption
injected maybe 0.4 million tons of so2
into the atmosphere so 40 times less
than pinatubo and not enough to have a
significant impact on the climate but
the eruption did have another global
atmospheric impact which may be a first
since observations began recall how the
displacement of water by the eruption
led to a tsunami in the ocean
well the eruption also displaced a lot
of material and put it into the
atmosphere and doing that
displaced a lot of air the displaced air
bunched up with surrounding air to
create what we call an over pressure but
then radiated out as a wave you can see
it really clearly in these satellite
images this over pressure wave was so
big and traveled so far that
meteorological stations have been
picking up its signal all over the
pacific across the united states and
even here in the uk
16 000 kilometers away but remember
because the atmosphere is just a fluid
that doesn't have any borders to it any
boundaries that overpressure wave can
just keep propagating around the world
some weather stations have actually
picked up the overpressure wave going
overhead and then about 36 hours later
picked it up again after the wave had
traveled around the world bounced back
from its antipode and came back overhead
but that's not the most amazing
unprecedented thing about this eruption
because that overpressure wave was so
powerful
it seems to have produced
a meteor tsunami
most waves are created by the action of
the atmosphere blowing over the ocean
you have two fluids one air one water
traveling at two different speeds the
boundary between those two fluids
naturally forms into waves by contrast a
meteor tsunami is caused by a sharp
pressure gradient or velocity gradient
in the atmospheric layer so there being
this really big contrast between lots of
air and then not very much air over a
relatively short span and that gradient
forces a wave to appear on the ocean
below meteor tsunamis are kind of common
they've been observed all over the world
and can be really quite big and
destructive for example three meter
meteor tsunamis have been observed on
the florida coast and a six meter meteor
tsunami on the croatian coast the
over-pressure wave from the tongan
eruption was so powerful that it seems
to have caused a meteor tsunami
something that as far as i can tell has
never happened before on the
instrumental record
and that's kind of extraordinary a
tsunami a meteor tsunami caused not by
the displacement of water but by the
displacement of air
by a volcanic eruption and the crazy
thing here is that because this over
pressure wave washed over the whole
planet the meteor tsunami wasn't just
limited to the pacific a small meteor
tsunami was measured in the caribbean
in an entirely different ocean basin
our planet's atmosphere and oceans are
really just enormous examples of fluid
flow and just like any two fluids they
can interact to produce amazing results
ocean atmosphere dynamics are absolutely
fascinating to me and this eruption
provided a really clear window into how
planetary scale fluids can interact a
volcanic eruption in the south pacific
caused an atmospheric wave that traveled
12 000 kilometers to the caribbean where
it initiated an ocean wave and we were
able to measure
all of that
and if you don't think that's amazing
i don't know what to tell you
this eruption and tsunami however have
been devastating to pacific communities
such as tonga and as of the time of
recording communications are still
really sparse now this video was
sponsored by fabulous and i'm going to
be donating that entire sponsorship fee
to the international federation of red
cross and red crescent societies who are
working to help those affected by the
disaster please do stick around for a
minute to find out where that money has
come from though because fabulous may
very well be able to help you too that's
because fabulous is an app developed by
a team originally at duke university's
behavioral economics lab designed to
help you build healthy daily habits the
app tailors your experience to what you
want to accomplish using it so do you
want to use it to improve your mental
health or your physical health or your
productivity or your mindfulness and
then using behavioral science it breaks
down the habits that you want to achieve
into really small tasks that are really
easy to do day by day and keeps track of
your progress in my particular case i
wanted to focus on productivity and
work-life balance my first step was
drinking water before i did anything
else in the morning a habit that has
successfully stuck after that i added
playing the piano to my morning routine
a few things during the workday and a
bedtime routine including deliberately
putting my phone to one side before bed
the app is personalized by you from the
moment you open it for the first time
though if you prefer you can take some
pre-made journeys picked out for you
believe me doing this stuff on your own
is hard and fabulous basically acts like
having a tiny hype man in your pocket
just gently encouraging you a couple of
times a day to be the best version of
yourself and to take care of yourself
using it for the past week has been a
really positive experience for me that i
can't
really put into words but it's made me
analyze my habits and i've definitely
seen some positive changes from it
already i'm gonna keep using it so if
that all sounds good start building your
ideal daily routines with fabulous the
first 100 people to go to the link in
the description will get 25 off their
subscription and i'd encourage you to
give it a go thanks again to fabulous
for supporting this video and for
allowing me to support the disaster
relief efforts in tonga and the pacific
thank you so much for watching the video
i've had some really split feelings on
this topic because on the one hand the
science here is really interesting and
potentially a world first and incredibly
beautiful but on the other hand this is
a real potential humanitarian disaster
that we just don't know enough about yet
so i hope with this video i've raised
some awareness of the science but also
of the situation in the pacific so
please do check out fabulous down there
in the description but also i'll leave a
link to the international federation of
red cross and red crescent societies if
you'd like to support the relief efforts
then please do make a donation there if
you enjoyed the video please do pop it a
like and maybe share it with people that
you think might also find it interesting
if you'd like to watch some more stuff
on youtube next then here's some
recommendations for you and that just
leads me to say thank you again for
watching i'll see you in the next one